calling all chocolate lovers yep i'm
talking to you clark on the steadicam
with this camera because he says i grew
up in switzerland before i say anything
this is all chocolate we got a big treat
for you take a look at these dazzling
works of edible art they are the
creations of french pastry chef amari
gushon is his name his designs are
featured on the netflix reality show
it's called school of chocolate and his
unlikely journey from struggling student
to chocolate connoisseur is now an
inspiration for many people this morning
we can reveal the show has been renewed
for a second season yey to that mark
straussman got the sweet assignment you
could say to visit the chef at his las
vegas culinary academy
amari gushon he's part picasso part
willy wonka a celebrated pastry chef
becoming world famous for bending
chocolate to his will and his
imagination
all of these 100 chocolate absolutely
yeah you can actually uh turn the
steering wheel which is also a fun added
feature you know making it a little bit
playful it's quite amazing chocolate is
beautiful
look at his sculpted masterworks a
roaring gorilla a motorcycle this
elephant
elaborate intricate each of them one
hundred percent
chocolate there is uh 1500 feathers
all of them were done by hand with the
tip of a knife and then assembled one by
one this one was very challenging
meticulous yeah
kind of draining
oh i was dead at the end of that day
it's a pterodactyl oh my god
gushon shares his secrets and skills on
his hit netflix series school of
chocolate
we're gonna have a 45-second window to
bend the chocolates eight contestants
all accomplished pastry chefs but
they've never been challenged like this
sorry you're really
reimagining
chocolate i'm trying to push the
boundaries yeah of what's doable
chocolate is so precious it's so unique
i still learn things about chocolate it
sounds stupid right it's just a liquid
blob of brown matter and yet you find
beauty every single time you work with
it
like his creations gushon's story feels
like a chocolate fairy tale he
floundered as a student in france when
gushan was 14 the school system pushed
him to learn a trade i was pushed into
choosing
either culinary or hair stylist so i
choose culinary you're telling me you
became a pastry genius because you were
a bad student
yeah and funny enough now i'm deep into
education so i'm on the other side my
old teenage years i was told that i was
too stupid to pursue any other things
it's sad but it's true and i was told
that i would never do anything good with
my life and now i'm 16 i'm in a field
where people consider lame so i'm like
let's be the best at it
a decade ago 21 and speaking no english
the chef moved to las vegas his
showmanship sparkled in this city of
glitz and he eventually started
showcasing his work on instagram
now 31 the chocolate charmer has more
than 6 million followers
his eye-popping images are produced by
his wife and co-ceo fiona
this master work is called
father nature this is my favorite piece
you know like every piece of art you
know you look at it gives you an emotion
the way i was able to capture the the
look on his face like an old soul you
know wise and calming
i didn't know i had it in me even his
most intricate creations take no more
than a week under the right conditions
gushon says they can last about 20 years
although admittedly losing a bit of
flavor so if i snapped off his head they
would taste okay you might punch me but
it's milk chocolate and it's delicious
gushon also founded this las vegas
pastry academy with chef michelle air
nuts over 10 weeks students learned the
craft and chemistry behind original
desserts
he gave me a shot at building something
simpler lemon tacos
[Music]
sorry
clearly some people should stay out of
the kitchen
but for gushan
this is the place where a chocolate
genius transforms the mundane
into the magical
i often say i'm not the best sculpture
you see some clay sculpture or wood
carving people who do some crazy amazing
thing the only thing that make me stand
out it's chocolate
uh okay
[Music]
very impressive love the guy great
backstory i wish him the most success in
the world but dude i hear a bite a piece
on chocolate don't need any chocolate
zero chocolate eaten the whole piece how
does it i wouldn't want to eat it i
think it's i love that that's what art
is taking something that's ordinary and
mundane and making something beautiful
and spectacular he's done that that's
really cool i wouldn't want it he said
that i wouldn't want to eat it but i was
curious tony to your point about what it
tasted like i was wondering that's like
chocolate but i still love i so love
this chef though i got caught up in his
in his story to be told that you're not
gonna amount to anything that you're
worthless i mean it's just another great
example of you can't let somebody else
define who you are he's an artist yes
but give me a hershey bar for everyday
chocolate you get one after the show